[Música]
gracias por acompañarme una semana más
en medioambiente desde casa en france 24
el 10% de todas las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero que contribuyen al
calentamiento global proviene de
alimentos que no son consumidos por el
ser humano y terminan en la basura o
dicho de otra manera si la pérdida y el
desperdicio de comida fuera en un país
serían el tercer mayor emisor de gases
contaminantes en el mundo después de
china y eeuu aunque estos dos conceptos
pérdida y desperdicio suenan igual no
son lo mismo
alimentos perdidos son todos aquellos
que se estropean o se descartan en la
producción transporte distribución y
procesamiento de estos mientras que el
desperdicio se refiere a los alimentos
que se echan a perder en la venta al por
menor y durante el consumo es decir los
que se pudren por ejemplo en tiendas
casas o restaurantes antes se calculaba
que esta contribución a las emisiones
era del 8% pero el último informe de wwf
titulado enviado a la basura revela que
el problema es mucho mayor al cálculo
anterior publicado en el índice de
desperdicio de alimentos del programa de
media
de las naciones unidas la nueva
información añade unos 1200 millones de
toneladas de alimentos perdidos en las
granjas lo que suma un total de 2.500
millones de toneladas de comida que se
van a la basura cada año o para ser más
claros el 40 por ciento de todos los
alimentos que se producen se estima que
de media en el mundo cada persona
desecha 74 kilos de comida al año la
investigación descubre que las
decisiones tomadas en los mercados e
incluso por el público influyen en los
niveles de pérdida de alimentos que
ocurren en la granja camilaca maher
coordinadora de sistemas alimentarios
sostenibles de w w de colombia nos
explicó qué significa esto lo que está
sucediendo es que esta comida se está
perdiendo es por criterios también de
consumo por criterios de mercado porque
no hay quien compre
alimentos que no tengan ese tipo de
estándares porque a veces por la
sobreoferta que hay de ciertos alimentos
o porque siempre queremos tener los
mismos alimentos disponibles en el
mercado estamos castigando otros
entonces creo que es un nuevo momento
para que reflexionemos como todos
asumimos esto es esta información que
estamos contándoles actualmente que los
alimentos terminan en la basura es
además una pérdida de recursos enorme
como el agua utilizada para su riego o
cría por ejemplo pero además hace que la
contaminación de suelos con pesticidas o
fertilizantes o la pérdida de
biodiversidad causada por la
modificación de terrenos para la
agricultura o la ganadería sean
sacrificios en vano sin embargo lo más
indignante de saber que más de dos
terceras partes de la comida que se
produce se vota es que en 2020 entre 720
y 811 millones de personas en el mundo
pasaron hambre y casi una de cada tres
personas en el planeta no tuvo acceso a
una dieta adecuada o saludable
precisamente para buscar soluciones a
esta situación se llevó a cabo en roma
la pre cumbre sobre los sistemas
mentarios cuyo evento principal se
celebrará a finales de año en nueva
york' fue la primera asamblea mundial
dedicada a la reforma profunda del modo
en el que se cultivan comercializan y
consumen los alimentos de esta cumbre
está haciendo que nos despertemos ante
el hecho de que debemos trabajar unidos
para transformar la manera en la que el
mundo produce consume y piensa sobre la
comida la precumbre me ha mostrado que
podemos cumplir con el derecho a la
alimentación mientras aseguramos el
futuro de nuestro planeta así como la
comida nos une como culturas y
comunidades también nos puede unir en
torno a soluciones uno de los 17
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible
adoptados en 2015 es el de garantizar
las maneras de consumo y producción
sostenibles y ahí está incluida la meta
de reducir a la mitad el desperdicio y
las pérdidas de alimentos per cápita de
aquí a 2030 una responsabilidad que es
compartida por todos los sectores de la
sociedad
si queremos promover el comprar en
temporada a los circuitos cortos
y conocer más acercarse más al campo
también aquellos alimentos que pueden
tener estándares diferentes en
apariencia es bien importante que
también lo reconozcamos siguen siendo
igualmente nutritivos también queremos
promover mucho que todos comemos mucho
más frutas y vegetales porque este es el
eslabón en donde más se pierde la comida
y donde hay mayor entre el valor
nutricional promueve la transformación
de otros actores de la cadena como
quienes nos ofrecen los alimentos pues
también nos ponen a disposición estas
alternativas que podrían ser frutas y
verduras que tengan algún tipo de
diferencia en términos pues de su
apariencia como les decía anteriormente
que nos pone estas góndolas que ya se
están utilizando por ejemplo con las
fechas de vencimiento por ejemplo en
términos de infraestructura en países
como como en latinoamérica en donde las
vías le implican unos retos para la
distribución de los alimentos donde no
hay tantos cuartos fríos donde los
centros de acopio pueden estar muy
distantes a los sitios de producción y a
veces sale más costoso
pagar un camión para que vaya a recoger
la cosecha que el valor que le pagan al
productor por la cosecha pues todo esto
necesitamos que cambien y tiene que ser
decisiones del mercado decisiones de los
compradores decisiones de política y
finalmente precisiones del consumidor
para lograrlo desde wwf insisten en que
es necesario que los gobiernos y
empresas adopten el enfoque de definir y
medir y actuar definir sus objetivos
específicos de reducción de pérdida y
desperdicio de alimentos medir las
cantidades que se pierden y desperdician
para así descubrir qué se necesita hacer
y dónde se necesitan implementar cambios
y finalmente actuar con estrategias
concretas para solventar esa
problemática su solución traerá ventajas
tanto para el ser humano como para el
planeta ya que mejorará la seguridad
alimentaria abordará el cambio climático
reduciendo así las emisiones y por lo
tanto el calentamiento global frenará la
pérdida de biodiversidad y el consumo de
recursos y traerá ahorros sustanciales a
las economías de los hogares de todo el
mundo los invito a volver a ver todas
las emisiones de medio ambiente en
nuestro canal de youtube y en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom